you first started doing more engineering
type stuff with uh Arduino boards at
punch through design which is an SF
engineering firm what are just from your
memory there what are some cool things
you built there
so the thing is I I went to add
words to like a vocational studies a
year and
there that I didn't care much for
advertising but I thought it was really
fun to build stuff and programs so like
I just completely focused on that and
there I built
my first Hardware project or like
Electronics project which was this
iPhone case with retractable guitar
strings so basically I imagine that you
could like pull out guitar strings from
the bottom of your iPhone and you could
pluck it to your belt and then you could
hold a cord on the screen and I built
that together with my friend Jonathan
and I was like oh this is dope I thought
it was so much fun and I considered like
oh should I go to school for this but
then I thought maybe I can get a job and
I could get paid to learn
about Electronics so just based off of
that one project I got the job at punch
through design there's actually was it
was one year internship can you explain
what we're talking about here so it's a
case with guitar strings attached yeah
does it actually work at all
it does these are not on the screen
guitar strings no so they're actual
strings that you pull out so there's a
mechanism that's almost like a seat belt
mechanism and
yeah you pull them out from the bottom
of uh your phone and you can attach them
to your belt I mean it's terrible
there's a few different ways to decide
if somebody's touching a guitar string
and what you do in a real guitar is you
have the little it's like measuring the
vibration or the change in the as as the
yeah you're measuring how the guitar is
vibrating and you can't really do that
because I can't have a a receiving
sensor because the guitar strings are
going to move in relationship to that
because you don't have like a rigid neck
and this is like yeah this was my first
Electronics project I was a little
fledging baby maker but what I decided
was to use capacitive touch
because that is independent on if the
guitar strings are moving in
relationship to something or in relation
to something so basically there was just
this little Bluetooth Arduino board that
this company punched through design made
so that was how I found them and I
measured the capacitive touch so like
whenever
um the guitar string was measured there
was this little microcontroller that was
like oh my God a guitar string got
measured or touched and then that sent a
signal over Bluetooth to my phone and
I'd built a little iPhone app that
interpreted those Bluetooth signals and
then checked what type of cord I was
holding on the screen and then played
the code here I see holding the chords
on the screen so you're doing the
multi-touch sensing there
that's incredible I honestly cannot
believe that I pulled it off because I
think I was I was ignorant was
definitely a bliss because that was like
yeah the first Hardware
project I'd ever built the first iPhone
app I'd ever programmed and like now if
somebody was like Hey I want this to be
my first project I would probably be
like oh that's a lot but
what can take it off because that's a
such an interesting thing for people to
hear because it's your first project and
a lot of people stop
because of the difficulty of the first
project they never truly discovered
their own genius because they stopped
with the first and you didn't stop so
it'd be interesting to kind of
psychoanalyze you on the couch of why
you didn't stop because you have to
build an app you have to figure out how
to did you know how to program much or
no okay I mean a little bit but I never
programmed and or done any iOS apps okay
so you have to figure out how to get
forget like what the app does just get
the app running and working and then you
have to figure out how to get the
sensors in like real time to finger
touching and you have to connect how to
get the capacitor's touch working with
the microcontrollers do you know
anything about the capacitor touch
sensors at that time I mean it's pretty
easy
um now it's basically everything's easy
yeah you know Rockets are pretty easy
you sound like my grandma because I have
an Italian grandma and uh I always
trying to get her we're like trying to
get her to tell her recipes and every
recipe starts with
it's very simple yeah and then there's
like 45 minutes of her explaining it
it's like with gymnastics at the
Olympics they make it look easy the best
people in the world always make the the
impossible to seem easy I pride myself
with making buildings that look really
hard because I feel like I'm always
struggling so much you make the easiest
human possible no uh
so how many strings was it this is just
oh gosh I think this is such a long time
ago no it was six oh six strings and you
could touch it and then there's
wow and they can and then the phone
itself makes a sound um and I still I
still think it's such a cool concept to
have this like mobile you know I'm not
even a guitar player I don't know I was
I mean I got the idea because I was uh
kind of strumming on my charge cord of
my phone oh like an air guitar but on a
chord yeah
been thinking about it because
I'm fine too go back to that project
with what I know
I know but the problem with it is that
when you're producing the tension in
your string just with your arm like you
can't make it taut enough to actually
play like it kind of becomes playing
these like saggy strings so it's you're
not really getting that experience and I
think that's why I mean I
yeah I haven't really pursued I wonder
if there's a way to generate the
tightness
from the case itself
it's a good device that unfolds and then
with some kind of tightening mechanisms
yeah but then it kind of becomes like
the whole thing in a good car then it
just becomes a really shitty guitar yeah
like which this is a really shitty
guitar but it's also but it's so shitty
it's awesome yeah I don't know I but
it's a cool it's cool that you have an
interface between
a device that's capable of incredible
computational power and an actual
Hardware thing is there something that
you can psychoanalyze
that made you finish that others could
hear
in their own struggle to uh
do their first project like that because
you were not you were in a
non-engineering person technically
and you did a pretty cool Renegade out
there
wild no instructions
engineering project no it's definitely
it was an off-road build where it's like
if you're building a Lego kit it's very
much on the road and you're following
instructions and this is like you have
no idea if you're headed for a clip or a
dead end or you're gonna get stuck
um I think it had a natural pressure to
it because it was a school project yeah
so it did have deadlines built into it
and and stuff like that so that
definitely helped but I think also it
was just so incredibly motivating when I
realized that I might be able to pull it
off
like that was I felt like a bloodhound
you know and you're just like oh my God
I can actually make this happen and I
think if
I hadn't seen that the Horizon it would
have been harder to stick through you
were you able to see the end of the
tunnel um
pretty early on no not really
so there's something just suffering for
a while I don't know how how your brain
works but it's like if I have a problem
I can't stop thinking about it like it's
so fun to think about it like I spent I
spent
two and a half years designing a coat
hanger
and I just can't stop thinking about it
like I get so into it because I think
it's so much fun
take me to this
two-year journey of the code hanger what
how did it begin how did it begin it
began with a corner in my home where I
couldn't fit a coat rack the thing is I
shouldn't have brought this up because
I'm gonna release it as a product
probably in a year on an actual product
okay well it is a mystery it's a mystery
yeah it solves a fundamental problem in
in The Human Condition and I am so
excited about it and I cannot I don't
yeah but this is I get so
pumped about it because I see it's just
this issue or like this problem that I
want to solve and I I kind of can't put
it to rest until I have